the protagonist of the movie is Manu a
homeless guy who does menial jobs for
cash he is so poor that he doesn't even
hesitate to do Shady work currently he
is living on a beach as he was kicked
out of his house for not paying his rent
on time one day as he is relaxing in the
son one of his old clients named Lush
approaches him he has brought a
proposition Manu will have to pick up a
suitcase from a t and deliver it to
another man during the whole process he
is not allowed to look inside the
suitcase as it contains something very
important and since the mission is
confidential he will have to transport
it in a car it is evident that the job
is illegal but Manu is so desperate for
money that he agrees without any
questions however there is one slight
problem he does not own a car he
politely asks if he can deliver the
suitcase by hand but Lush angrily
refuses saying a vehicle is a must after
the guy departs Manu starts looking for
a car since he doesn't have money to buy
one he resorts to stealing one he
eventually finds an old model and drives
it to his best friend Jean go Manu
doesn't want to proceed with the mission
alone so he asks Jean go to join him he
proposes that they split the money in
half since the ladder is also desperate
for Cash He agrees right away later as
the two are on their way to their
destination they hear some strange
noises coming from the trunk they
dismiss it as the engine but the sound
keeps growing louder and louder shortly
after the car suddenly stops in the
middle of the road but the noise still
persists confirming that it is not the
engine the guys then nervously open the
trunk to check only to find a massive
fly kept there this shocks the two as
the insect looks like it has come from
another planet they promptly close the
trunk and start discussing their next
move Manu wants to throw the fly away so
that they can make room for the suitcase
they are about to pick up however when
he tries opening the trunk it gets stuck
this leaves him worried as Lush has
instructed him to keep the suitcase
inside the TR trunk as he struggles to
come up with a solution an idea strikes
John gob's mind he proposes that they
tame the insect and teach it how to
steal money and food from others this
will be worth way more than the 500
they're about to get from their target
Manu likes the idea so he immediately
gets on board the two then quit their
current Mission and decide to focus on
the fly but at first they will need a
place to stay as the insect cannot be
seen in public after a while of
wandering around they spot an old
trailer because they are in the middle
of nowhere they decide that it is the
perfect place to train the fly the only
problem is that an old man lives inside
it but Manu has a solution for
everything he engages the man in a
conversation before knocking him out
from behind the two friends then tie him
to a barrel and take over the trailer
while searching around the place they
find food tools and even a gun Manu has
never used one in his life but
nonetheless he keeps it for protection
the two then use the tools to finally
open the car's truck trunk after this
they decide to bring the fly inside and
tie duct tape around it so that it
doesn't escape just then the Old Man
reveals that he is hidden €3,000 nearby
and he will gladly give it to them if
they let him go free Manu doesn't even
question him and he agrees to escort him
there meanwhile Jean Gob decides to stay
in the trailer and look after the fly
along the way monu stops the car and
starts searching around for the gun this
gives the old man enough time to open
the door and make a run for it but by
the time Manu realizes what has happened
it's too late he returns home and sadly
tells his friend that he didn't get the
money to his rage Jean goab has bought
cat food with the remaining cash they
had he explains that they have to feed
the fly first as it is their only hope
of Survival by the evening the creature
devours all the food but it is still
hungry the friends are also starving as
they haven't eaten anything in 24 hours
so the very next morning they come up
with a risky plan using the gun from
earlier they threaten a stranger and
force him to buy groceries for them when
they return home Manu immediately gets
to cooking while Jean Gob starts
training the fly he lovingly names it
Dominique after his ex-girlfriend the
fly appears to be a quick learner but it
will take several days before it can
start understanding commands while the
two friends are engrossed in
conversation Manu forgets that the gas
stove is on because of this the kitchen
and subsequently the whole trailer
catches fire Manu barely manages to
escape with a pot of broth now the two
have become homeless again but at least
they have a vision in mind they spend
the evening taking sips from the broth
while also feeding it to the insect that
night they then try to sleep in the car
but Manu is clearly uncomfortable
because of Dominique's strange noises
thus he gets out and sleeps in the open
in the morning he proposes that they
sell the car and get a better one where
they can sleep comfortably however when
they try to drive away in the car it
doesn't start Manu then comes up with
yet another solution he he uses a pony
bicycle to drag the car to the
dealership along the way they are
stopped by a group of youngsters one of
the girls named Cecil thinks Manu is her
school friend Fred he tries to explain
that he isn't the one but she is so
excited to meet him after long that she
doesn't pay attention she then invites
the two to her Farmhouse where they will
be going on a vacation this is music to
Manu and Jean gob's ears as they can
finally have a proper place to stay upon
arriving at the house they park the car
at a distance and lock Dominique inside
it they then sit by the pool and have
some drinks Cecil's brother Serge is
angry that she invited strangers to
their house but he doesn't say anything
at the moment when night falls Cecil
guides them to their rooms saying they
can live here as long as they want to
monu is delighted about it but jean Gob
is concerned for his pet fly later Cecil
brings out her school's yearbook and
shows Manu the picture of this Fred guy
to his surprise they look exactly the
same like they're twins the SE then cuts
to the dinner and we are introduced to
Cecil's sister Agnes she suffers from a
strange condition which causes her to
talk in a very loud tone it's almost as
if she is screaming all the time Cecil
then reveals that Agnes hit her head
when she was a little girl and from that
day on she has never spoken in a soft
tone following dinner Jean Gob secretly
goes to his car retrieves Dominique and
brings it to his room he then starts
playing and training with it on the
other hand Manu goes to his room but he
finds out agess already there he tries
to initiate a conversation but she
mistakes it for flirting and kicks him
out Manu then goes to his friend's room
but jean Gob doesn't allow him in as he
has to train the fly as a result Manu is
forced to spend the night by the pool
the next morning Agnes confronts John
Gob outside his room suspicious that he
is hiding someone inside she claims that
she heard him chatting all night since
John Gob cannot reveal about the massive
fly he makes up a lie that it's his pet
dog this unfortunately makes Agnes even
more Furious as dogs are strictly not
allowed in the house she vows to tell
her sister and kick him out of the house
after she leaves Jean goab anxiously
summons Manu and explains the entire
predicament he requests him to find a
dog as soon as possible or else they
will be in trouble Manu is enraged by
the sudden mess up but he agrees to help
to his luck he finds a stray puppy right
outside the block he then sneaks it
inside and hands it to his friend
elsewhere Agnes tells the others that
there is a dog in the house they try to
ignore her as she is notorious for
making things up but when she continues
to insist they reluctantly agree to
check the room the group then heads
there to find out what's really going on
to their shock they find Manu holding
the tiny puppy he makes up AABB story
saying he adopted the dog because it had
nowhere to go he then apologizes for not
informing them about it Cecil is Smitten
by his selflessness and she allows the
dog to stay However Agnes and serge have
started to to get suspicious the noises
last night didn't sound like a puppy
they sounded like a giant fly after
everyone leaves Jean go shows Manu a
trick that he has taught the fly it has
now started obeying his commands and can
even move to his signals this Delights
the duo and they think that it's only a
matter of time before Dominique can
steal food for them later the two jump
in the pool and start playing like kids
Agnes is by the pool and she is visibly
upset by the noise they're making back
inside the room Dominique is left alone
with the tiny puppy the two stare at
each other for a while before the fly
lunges at the dog at the pool Manu and
Jean Gob are still making loud noises
this irritates Agnes so much that she
curses at them and heads inside the
house she then tries getting into Jean
gob's room suspecting that he is hiding
something the door is locked but she
manages to open it using her hair pin
Agnes then enters the room only to find
a humongous fly there terrified she
screams the loudest she ever has causing
everyone to rush rush to the room when
they ask what happened Agnes fails to
say anything because of the shock
meanwhile Jean Gob finds the dog's leash
and realizes that Dominique ate it the
others however think that Agnes is the
one that ate it so they call the cops on
her after a while Jean Gob eventually
finds Dominique near the pool and
secretly hides it in the car in the next
scene the cops deem Agnes insane and
decide to admit her to the hospital
before she is taken away she speaks to
her sister she surprisingly talks in a
normal tone for the first time in years
Agnes explains everything that she saw
in that room however Cecil doesn't
believe her later as one of the officers
is talking to Cecil he recognizes her as
his old classmate he is none other than
Fred the guy who resembles Manu to prove
it he shows a tattoo on his leg that he
got during his school days this leaves
Cecil stunned and she finally realizes
that the two guys are imposters the cops
then proceed to arrest them for fraud
but before that Manu and John Gob
managed to escape in their car now that
they have nowhere to go and no money to
feed the fly they decide to continue
their earlier Mission despite being 3
days late they head to the target's
location and Acquire The Briefcase they
then head to the second target who turns
out to be a wealthy businessman the guys
hand over the briefcase to him and get
paid €500 at this moment they discover
that the briefcase contained nothing but
some ornaments this guys most love
Christmas the movie then cuts to a few
days later and we see that the two have
started Living on the beach again Jean
Gob appears to be excited as he has
finally completed his training with the
fly he gets a newspaper and shows a
picture of bananas to Dominique he hopes
that the insect will fetch the fruit for
them however as soon as he unties the
creature it just flies away Jean Gob
still hopes that it will return but Manu
is sure that it won't now that they're
back to square one they get emotional
and start talking about friendship Manu
says that they don't need the fly as
they have each other to rely on and that
is the most important gift one can get
jean go nods his head in agreement but
he is still distraught that his pet left
him the two then get inside the car and
start the engine but as they are about
to leave Dominique suddenly appears with
a bunch of
bananas subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching